we were talking about the trans thing a
second ago uh gender i've noticed it
seems like correct me from wrong but it
seems like you're
in recent months you've been focusing
especially on on gender issues yeah um
going back to the infamous harry styles
your
your controversial opinion that you
don't think men should wear dresses i
don't know how you could possibly say
such a thing
uh but so there's that and then there's
the women the men in sports and all
those sorts of things
i think that the gender issues have been
i've been saying for years that this
is one of the central battlefields of
the culture award it's time for
conservatives to wake up to it and start
engaging
this is not a sideshow uh it felt for
for so long the conservatives said well
this is a
fad it'll go away it's not so what am i
correct that you've been
focusing on this more and if so why why
is this important do you think so i
actually haven't been focusing on it
more
it's just that it's kind of finally come
to fruition uh which you know you
predicted it i predicted it so
three years ago when i was first
speaking out i was like watch this
because this is something that you think
oh oh it's it's less than one percent of
the population it's you know it's
it's not going to ever be a thing and i
was like i just kind of saw it
kind of brewing and i had done tons of
episodes on my
show my previous shows talking about it
when i was sitting college campuses i
was talking about it
and then it feels like sort of in the
last six months they sort of became
really obsessed with now even calling a
woman a woman is wrong right like even
trying to say
in all of these terms womanx i don't
even say it womex women's
womenics mixing mixing we're mixing
mixing we'll mix in yes right i also
thought
i thought it was la tinx but i'm told
that it's a latin x no let's go with the
tanks
right and which is hilarious because if
you ever use the word latinx it's the
easiest way to discern that someone is
not actually latino or latina because
they'd have to
do away with the entire language
everything is a gender in spanish
la mesa that's table like it's like boy
or girl for everything
um but yeah so i just saw it coming and
i wanted to really assert myself
on that issue because it is i mean it is
just the greatest undoing trying to
you get to a destroy families weaken
society i mean you can do
everything through it through the
transgender movement that the left is
really after which is just chaos
um so yeah i just spoke out against it
and i will say this like i said earlier
it is the one issue that black americans
are the most uncomfortable with
and so i have not you know i've seen
black americans across
both sides of the political spectrum say
okay i'm this she's 100 right
which makes sense because if you pull
black america in terms of their politics
they've never
been big supporters of the lgbt
q r n s
e t that's also b you don't yeah
whatever it is
i just say the whole alphabet but you
say that black americans don't support
this and i've
i've heard that before but you don't
hear that that voice the voice is heard
through you but it's not
they don't they don't have very many um
outlets to express that i mean blm for
example
is at least before they scrub their
their page that you know laid out their
whole agenda the stuff about
uh tearing down the families yeah the
families they took a lot of that stuff
off but
before they took that stuff off you read
it and you thought well this is just a
this is an lgbt group
there's very little here even about race
it's mostly about trans and
um so is that uh
why don't we hear that expressed more i
mean is it yeah
you know i think you do it's just not
given it's not given air so like i
definitely have heard
charlemagne the god right on the
breakfast club talk about
various political issues and he will
always give they will always side
on the candace is right on this one you
know and
and definitely throughout the harry
styles thing
actually it was the first time black
twitter ever came to my defense by the
way
as they call it hashtag black twitter um
because you know noah cyrus miley cyrus
apparently has a little sister and she
jumped in to defend harry styles
and in the process called me like a
nappy-headed hoe and then it kind of
went viral on instagram and they were
all talking about the issues saying
this is this is just not something we
accept but the media won't cover it so
it sort of
exists in this bubble on social media
whereas i i know you speak to
black americans they never ever ever
have attacked me on my position on
women or women and men or men and i
think that they really see that as an
attack on
black men you know and it's an attack on
all men you know what it means to be a
man
and we already have so many issues when
it comes to father
fathers in the home and what it means to
be a man in black america as is so it's
just not something that they're going to
get behind so it's a losing issue
for democrats which is why i'm okay with
them trying to force this down people's
throats because in my opinion you start
calling a black woman's
child you know her son by a female name
and you're going to wake up
you know a sleeping a sleeping giant